ein staatsoberhaupt am strand zu sehen
das passiert sowieso schon nicht so oft
und dann noch als lebensretter genau das
ist jetzt aber passiert in portugal
dort hat der präsident dabei geholfen
zwei mädchen vor dem ertrinken zu retten
die jugendlichen waren in einem kajak
vor der küste im süden portugals
unterwegs als sie plötzlich kenterten
und von der strömung mitgerissen wurden
doch sie hatten glück in ihre missliche
lage war nicht unbeobachtet geblieben
und kein geringerer als der
portugiesische präsident zögert keine
sekunde sondern sprang sofort ins wasser
zusammen mit einem weiteren schwimmer
schaffte es der 71-jährige des super die
mädchen und ihr kajak von der strömung
wegzuschieben
es hat ihnen einen heiden schreck
eingejagt so dass schuster nach der
rettungsaktion
sie haben eine menge wasser geschluckt
sie müssen vorsichtiger sein selbst wenn
man gut schwimmen kann und eine
schwimmweste trägt ist es sehr
gefährlich in ihrem alter allein in
einem kajak unterwegs zu sein dass das
süße ausgerechnet an diesem tag an
diesem strand war war reiner zufall
er ist aktuell auf werbetour für sein
land und hatte angekündigt dafür an
seinen wochenenden verschiedene orte an
der algarve küste zu besuchen